HAL BAILEY: Hello.
My name's Hal Bailey.
And I'm excited today.
Kal and I met several years
ago in San Francisco.
And I'm thrilled today to
have him here at Google.
We've been talking about
this many years.
Two of the things that I think
will resonate with most people
here about Kal and his work are
one, he spends a lot of
time and effort thinking about
the digital revolution.
How the digital revolution is
changing both books, but also
art in general.
And then also, he's been very
vocal about freedom of
expression, not just in the
United States and the United
Kingdom, where it's easy
to do that, but around
the world as well.
So he's got lots of interesting
stories to tell us.
And I'll hand it over to him.
KEVIN KALLAUGHER: Great.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, Hal.
[APPLAUSE]
KEVIN KALLAUGHER: Thanks,
everyone.
Good to see you.
Thank you.
Thank you all for
coming today.
We're going to have some fun
today, partly because we're
going to be talking
a little bit about
the world of cartoons.
Political cartoons, which
innately should be fun.
But also, I'm going to have a
little bit of fun because the
world of cartoons has been
shrinking of late.
And what I mean is the
traditional cartoon that
everyone knows about appears
in a newspaper.
And soon, we may be saying,
what was the newspaper, as
everyone's attention moves to
the internet and absorbing
content on new devices.
And so, the numbers of political
cartoonists my
particular craft, has reduced,
I think in 25 years, from
about 200 in the
US to about 70.
And those numbers will
probably get smaller.
And around the rest of the
world, there may be only
another hundred of us
that are doing this.
But today, we're going to change
all that, because in
addition to me telling you a
little bit about the world of
cartoons that I reside in,
showing you some cartoons,
doing a Q&A, I'm also going to
draw some of my favorite
presidents that I've drawn
over the years.
But we're going to finish off
with a drawing lesson, where
I'm going to teach everybody
here how to draw Barack Obama.
OK?
So we're going to have like,
another 50 cartoonists by the
end of the show.
We hope that you guys
will practice.
And then we'll start a new
revolution starting today.
So anyways, my world.
Editorial cartoonist.
I've been with "The Economist"
magazine for 35 years.
And many of you have copies of
the book that just came out
about a month ago celebrating
that fact.
And during my career, both for
"The Economist" and as
cartoonist is for "The Baltimore
Sun," where I had
been, I've created over
8,000 cartoons.
And I've created over
140 covers for
the magazine as well.
And I wanted to give you guys
a little bit of insight into
this very special type of
creativity that's involved in
my craft, which requires both
the understanding of politics
and art, and done
on a deadline.
But the thing that fascinates me
most about my craft is the
notion that you're dealing
with a certain kind of
technology.
And the technology is pigment,
black pigment, on a white
piece of paper.
And when you see it appear in
front of you, it's completely
individual, as individual as
each of our handwriting.
Yet when it appears, suddenly
an image arrives.
And everyone, no matter what
nationality, what language you
speak, it will be universally
understood.
And there is no special
effects with this.
It's exactly what you see.
There's something very human
and very tangible about the
act of drawing.
But then, there's also something
about the power that
this line can create.
And we only have to think about
what happened to a group
of Danish cartoonists just a few
years ago, when they drew
the Prophet Mohammad.
There were subsequent riots,
where hundreds
of people were killed.
And it caused an international
outcry that still is an open
wound today.
So besides the fact that there's
a magic to this line,
there's also a power
to this line.
And I'm going to share with you
guys a little bit of the
inside of what it's like
to be a cartoonist.
Some of the skill
sets involved.
Some of the background stories
that go into it, particularly
with my work with the
"Economist." And then, we'll
have some fun doing some
drawing as well.
So I thought I'd start--
I think it's a really important
thing when you're
dealing with artists, it's
really important to look at
their early work.
You get some sort of sense
of where they come from.
And I'm going to show you this
cartoon, which is a seminal
cartoons of mine.
Very important cartoon,
which I drew when I
was six years old.
So now, this cartoon
is important.
You might see it's got Abraham
Lincoln, "Gettysburg Address."
The reason why this cartoon is
so important is because this
cartoon inspired a feature
length motion picture starring
Daniel Day Lewis.
[LAUGHTER]
KEVIN KALLAUGHER: It's a
really important piece.
But here's what's
cool about this.
At age six, everybody in
this room is drawing.
Right?
We are all drawing.
But somewhere between six and
13, most people drop off.
But we all have that in us, that
capacity to use lines to
dictate reality, to
translate reality.
It's all something
that we absorb,
life through the lines.
And for me as a cartoonist, I'm
actually a professional
six-year-old.
I kind of stayed with
this world of lines.
So after graduating from
Harvard, I spent the next 11
years living in the UK.
But I started as-- you're not
going to believe this--
a semi-professional
basketball player.
I was always taller back then.
But I also, when the team is
having financial trouble, I
went on the streets and started
drawing caricatures.
And one of things when you're
a street artist, you get to
see hundreds, if not thousands,
of faces.
And you see people of all
different nationalities, all
different shapes of heads,
all different ages and
ethnicities.
And you learn to deconstruct
and understand the
complexities of the face.
And the unfortunate thing,
though, is I was doing this to
raise money.
And you can imagine the typical
caricaturists knock
something out, what?
In about three or
four minutes.
And they put a tennis racquet
in the person's hand.
And they charge you whatever.
I was a terrible businessman,
because it used to take me a
half an hour or 45 minutes.
Because I wanted to capture
that person.
The spirit of that individual.
And I thought I was mad until
I read a famous quote by the
Italian Renaissance painter,
Annibale Carracci, who said,
"A good caricature is more
true to life than reality
itself."
And it's this whole idea that
you can get to the soul of
someone through a caricature
that's always inspired me.
So when I started working for
"The Economist" magazine back
in 1978, I now was no longer
drawing holidaymakers.
I was now drawing
policymakers.
And I was beginning to realize
and understand that the
cartoon, the caricature, was
not just a source of making
humorous assertions of people on
the streets, but now you're
taking on powerful people,
and you could
knock them down a notch.
And over this time, I've
drawn, wow, I've drawn
practically every major
politician over the years.
Certainly every American
president.
And some of the American
presidents obviously offered
more scope than others.
And I also found the caricatures
I was drawing were
not simply representations of
the individuals, but they also
were telling stories.
This cartoon, for example,
appeared on the cover of the
magazine "The Economist" not
long after Hurricane Katrina.
But it was a metaphor of how
the Bush administration and
their policies were also falling
apart in the same way
that the country was.
And this is the only cover in
over 150 years "The Economist"
ran with no words on it.
And then, of course, caricatures
of individual
presidents who I've drawn
change over time.
Partly because we all
But we've also seen how
Obama's has changed.
This is what he look like
in 2008 when he
ran the first time.
You guys remember this guy,
the upward looking, the
optimistic, the hopeful
president?
And now, five years later, this
is what he looks like.
So the weight of the job, and
the gravity, and gravitas are
kind of pulling its weight and
taking a toll on the face.
And so the drawing can
tell the story.
And the other thing that I
learned when I was watching
caricatures over time was it
was that people's shape of
your head is the most
distinguishing characteristic
that you have.
And so someone like John Kerry,
who's got a very long
face, made it good
for caricature.
And there's other guys, like
Joe Biden here, where the
smile gives a shape of its own
and creates the fundamental
part of the recognition
of the face.
Now it's also a point that I
discovered over time that the
caricatures are not just
reflecting the important
people in the news, but they
can also be educational
components, where they're
telling the readers who are
the people, important people,
that you should know about.
So someone like Nancy Pelosi,
who everyone wouldn't
necessarily recognize if she
walked into the room, or
Senator Reid of Nevada.
But these are important
people.
If you put them in cartoons,
then people say, oh, maybe I
should know who these
people are.
And then there's election
years, where we have new
candidates coming along and
new challenges for the
cartoonist and the
caricaturist.
So I was in the UK, like I
said, for about 11 years.
And I hadn't been there for very
long before I realized
that as an American living
abroad, you are held
personally responsible for
everything that goes on in
this country.
So as a result, I became more
aware and more interested in
politics to try to figure
out what was going on.
Partly because I learned that
every taxi driver in London
seemed to know more about
American politics than I did.
But I figured that I needed
to get my game up.
So I got this new interest in
politics, and I combined it
with my interest in cartoons
to become a political
cartoonist.
Here, I was using caricature,
the skill set that I felt was
really one the most powerful
tools at the
disposal of a satirist.
But I was also using it
as a way to get your
interest into a cartoon.
At that point, I deliver
a message.
And that makes the
good cartoon.
So because my job is not really
to make you laugh.
My job is to make you think
using humor, using caricature,
but using it as a vehicle
for a message.
And after that, hopefully,
making you challenge your
thoughts and your ideas on the
important events of the day.
So I will use caricatures.
I thought caricatures
are great.
To quote another famous person,
another great British
philosopher named Mary Poppins,
"A spoonful of sugar
helps the medicine go down." And
because we are animals and
we are wired to look at faces,
whereby our eyes are scanners,
our brains are hard drives, and
all we do is every time we
look at the person, we're
eyeballing and we're assessing
them to see if they're friendly,
if we like them, are
they attractive, would I like
to go out with them, or
whatever you're thinking.
Your brain is processing this
information instantaneously.
The caricature is the thing that
brings your eyeballs into
the cartoon.
And when you have them in there
for five or six seconds,
then you can deliver your
message at the same time.
So now, I'm going to show you
some of the other tools in
addition to caricature that we
cartoonists use to get our
messages across.
So one of them, of course,
is symbols.
The donkey and the elephant,
most famously in the United
States, representative of
two different parties.
Use them, of course,
in many cartoons.
This cartoon, for example,
I did in 2010 during the
mid-term elections.
Normally when the opposition
party gains an upper hand.
We might expect to see
the same cartoon
again in 2014, perhaps.
Although I never recycle
cartoons.
I want to make that clear.
All right.
So here's another famous symbol,
our friend Uncle Sam.
So this cartoon I did after
a visit to Cuba in 1999.
And there, you can
see Uncle Sam.
He's got his microphone.
He's going, "People of Cuba!
Why stick with that dictator
idiot Castro when you can
freely elect your idiots
like we do?"
And that was during the time
of the Monica Lewinsky
nonsense and all that
stuff going on in
the background there.
And then this cartoon about
Uncle Sam, one of my
favorites, has Uncle Sam, "What
foreign enemies think
Americans are looking for,
world control." "What
Americans are really
looking for is,
remote control." Right?
Again, our good friend
Uncle Sam.
Now, there's also, of course,
cartoons that are
not funny at all.
When I live the job of an
editorial cartoonist, I live
within two polarities.
Editorial that is serious and
cartoonist that is funny.
And every day when I approach my
cartoons, I put myself on a
different part of that spectrum
according to the
appropriateness of the
subject matter.
And you guys all have to think
back to what it was like in
the United States after 2001 and
the bombings in New York.
And any of you that've lived
abroad in countries where
they've had major terrorist
activity, is that there's not
a lot of humor to be found.
At those times, you have
to resort to other of
your skill sets. .
This cartoon, for example, I
did a few days afterwards.
And it's about terrorism.
And it's about the beast of
terrorism that is both visible
and invisible.
A beast that you will not slay,
but one that must be
engaged just the same.
But eventually over time, humor
does find its way back
into the discussion.
And actually, I think humor is
an important part of the
healing process.
And cartoonists often lead the
way as being some of the first
people to approach this
sort of thing.
And here's a cartoon I wanted
to show you that tells you a
little bit of a story about
what happened after 9/11.
And in fact, in four panels, it
tells the entire story of
the decade long Iraq war.
So it starts off, we have Uncle
Sam, who thinks he sees
weapons of mass destruction.
And he's going in.
And once he's in there,
where do they go?
They weren't here.
And oh no, it's worse
than I thought.
And then finally, oh,
there they are.
We finally found the weapons
of mass destruction.
Maybe not exactly where
we thought they were.
AUDIENCE: And you're mooning
[INAUDIBLE].
KEVIN KALLAUGHER:
That's right.
So here, what's interesting too
is that note, this employs
yet another tool for
the cartoonist.
And that is narrative
storytelling.
Most of the cartoons you've
seen up to now
had a single panel.
This one went over
several panels.
You're telling a story.
So being a cartoonist, you
also have to be a good
storyteller.
You have to be not only good
with pictures, but you have to
be good with timing.
This, by the way, I just wanted
to show you, is what
Iraq looks like today.
This is much more of where we
stand, where Iraq is trying to
set off after the US is pulling
its hands away.
But it doesn't look like it's
going to move so steadily.
I'll also add, for those of you
who've spent any time in
England, you may know
in England--
well here in the US we say, on
your marks, get set, go.
In England, they say,
ready, steady, go.
And hence, that's why this
is ready, steady.
If this was done for "The
Baltimore Sun," it would've
said, on your marks, get set.
And then everyone would have
known what happened.
So we also do cartoons on a
whole array of subjects that
are not necessarily specific to
individuals, where you have
caricature, or symbols like
Uncle Sam, but they could be a
much more grander process.
This brings me around to the
point of saying that when
you're a cartoonist, the
world is our bailiwick.
We have to cover everything.
All the other writers and
columnists and newspapers,
they usually have certain
specific niches.
As a cartoonist, I have to cover
everything, which means
keeping up with the news, which
is I think is the part
of the my job that's
the hardest for
me to keep up with.
We have to do very sensitive
subjects
as well, like religion.
OK.
Here's a cartoon I wanted to
show you about religion.
It's set up in heaven.
And it says, "Hello, Lord
Almighty's office.
Michael be Archangel speaking.
May I help you?"" And a voice
from offstage says, "Who is
it?" "It's Pope John Paul II
on the line." "Again?"
"He's worried about this
movement to ordain women as
priests." "But I've already
told him what I think.
Tell him I'm busy."
"I'm sorry.
She's
busy right now." [LAUGHTER]
KEVIN KALLAUGHER: So here, one
of the other elements of being
a cartoonist is you've got
to be a good writer.
And here we have writing, and
timing, and panels all wrapped
into one, because we had the
lead to the words to the last
few seconds.
Not giving away our hand.
And so having all of that--
and this is what it looked
like in the paper--
having all of that work out in
a nice continuum that made it
an effective joke.
Now we also cover tough
subjects like guns.
All right.
Now guns is a subject which
I've done many cartoons.
This is the cover of "The
Economist" that I did the week
that Gabrielle Giffords got
shot down in Arizona.
This is a very touchy subject.
Every country and every
individual has
certain touchy subjects.
And here, of course, guns
is one of them.
So recently, I was in Beirut.
And I was talking to a group
of Lebanese cartoonists,
showing my cartoons.
And one of the cartoonists was
aware of the amount of gun
cartoons I did.
And he says, you've got to tell
me, Kal, do you ever get
worried that people will get
very upset about these kinds
of toons and do something
about it?
Because after all, all those
guys that you're complaining
about guns, they've
all got guns.
And I thought, well, I've
been lucky so far.
I've had cartoonists colleagues
both here and
abroad who have been
threatened and
this sort of thing.
But it's not been such
an issue for me.
But then another Lebanese
cartoonist perked up.
And he said, you know,
here in Lebanon, it's
the exact same thing.
Except everyone here has
got rocket launchers.
So it made me feel an awful lot
better, that conversation.
I didn't feel so under siege.
Now this cartoon is one about
the financial world.
This is my most popular
cartoon ever.
It's just a normal day at the
nation's most important
financial institution.
So this little guy there on the
left, he's saying, "I've
got a stock here that could
really excel." "Really excel?"
"Excel?" "Sell?" "Sell?" "Sell!"
"Sell!" Sell!" "Sell!"
"Sell!" "Sell!" "Sell!"
"This is madness.
I can't take anymore.
Good bye." "Good bye?" "Bye?"
"Buy?" "Buy?" "Buy?" "Buy?"
"Buy?" "I've got a stock here
that could really excel."
So anyway, so this cartoon
appears 1989.
It appears "Baltimore Sun,"
"New York Times," "Herald
Tribune." Starts picked up
by other newspapers.
And the next thing you know,
I'm getting phone calls.
Scores of phone calls
from stockbrokers.
And they're saying two things.
One, they want a copy
of this cartoon.
And two, this is exactly
what its like.
This is what they all say.
And ever since then, on almost a
weekly basis, I get requests
to use this cartoon in books,
encyclopedias, on mugs.
I had that request six months
ago from a stockbroker in Hong
Kong, where we took this
cartoon, they blew it up.
We divided it and made it one
single line, 24 feet.
And they put it in the
lobby of their place.
So it's amazing.
Some cartoons can really hit a
raw nerve if you get it right.
And some cartoons, of course,
we're always about trying
getting things down
to their simplest.
But sometimes, keeping things
complex are also great ways to
tell the story.
So this is about Obamacare,
navigating US health.
Before Obamacare, this is
what it looks like.
And after Obamacare, this is
what it's going to look like.
.
So it's a great way of telling
the story in pictures.
So this is kind of what I
thought your relationship to
China is here, between
Google and China.
There is nothing more
annoying on the web
than an unwanted pop-up.
And that's a Chinese dragon kind
of finding its way into
everything you do here.
So anyways, for the outside
world, this is what we think
you guys at Google are like.
You don't have your shoes on.
You always got a hat on.
And you're always just
tapping away.
So hopefully I'm going
you learn something.
So the cartoon I do on Google
will be a little bit more
representative.
So always as cartoonists, we're
always ingesting as much
information as we can about the
subjects we're covering.
Now I want to show you a quick
notice about how cartoons have
progressed over recent years.
And this is a pre-internet
cartoon I
want to tell you about.
So the story is this.
Mikhail Gorbachev is
now the new leader
of the Soviet Union.
1986, I think.
And I was working in
the UK at the time.
And there was this brand new
show called "Miami Vice." You
guys know that?
Brand new in 1986.
And I say, wouldn't it be cool
to get this new cool new style
leader and draw him as the guy
from "Miami Vice." And the
editors at "The Economist" said,
great, Kal, go for it.
I had 24 hours to complete
the cover.
But the bad news was I got home
and I realized I had no
photos of "Miami Vice."
And in those days, if you didn't
have any photos, you
had no photos.
There was no way to
get anything.
And so I turned to my wife and
I said, well, what are we
going to do?
So we said, what do we do?
The typical thing,
we went shopping.
We went out and bought
some clothes.
And this is me modeling for
the actual cartoon.
Of course, that's not my car.
That's not really my car.
But those are my clothes that
Mikhail Gorbachev is wearing
in the cartoon.
So that was pre-internet.
So here's a cartoon
post-internet.
So the story of this
cartoon took place
about five years ago.
I was on vacation in the Big
Horn Mountains of Wyoming,
Northeast Wyoming.
And I made the mistake
of checking my email.
There was a note from "The
Economist" saying, , Kal, you
left a sketch for us that we
really liked about the
over-consumption of
oil between the
United States and China.
And would you please paint it.
We want to put it on the
cover this week.
So I get back to them with a
note and say, guys, there's
three problems.
First, I'm on vacation.
Second, I don't have
any paints with me.
And third, I'm in the
middle of nowhere.
Right?
So I figured that kind of
will settle the score.
But then they get back to me and
say, Kal, see what you can
do and call us in the morning.
So I'm going, oh man.
All right.
So I'm at a dude range.
And so, I go talk
to the dudes.
I go, dudes, where can
I get some paints?
And they say, well, this
dirt road, 10 miles.
Go down there.
There's a pharmacy.
In the back row of the pharmacy,
there's a lady.
She likes to paint.
Go talk with her.
Go find the lady.
She gives me a little
kids' pack.
You know the little six?
Them round little things?
That's what I got.
Little six pack of kid paints.
One piece of watercolor paper.
And I go back to the kitchen
table of the dude
ranch, and I do this.
And notice the primary
colors here.
It's very basic colors
in this.
And then I scan it on my
portable scanner laptop.
Email it, like dial-up.
Five hours later, it
arrives in London.
But the key thing was that two
days later, being "The
Economist," this appeared in
every country around the world
from the mountains of Wyoming.
And ever since then and actually
before, wherever I am
in the world, I'm always doing
my cartoons for "The
Economist." And it's
a very easy thing.
Particularly compared to what
it was when I first started
with "The Economist."
It was 1978.
I worked in UK.
I came back to Baltimore
to New York in the
United States in 1988.
And the internet was just
in its early days.
And I pioneered the use of
sending my cartoons to London
from Baltimore.
But in those days, a 400K
file would take
three hours to send.
And now, of course, we could be
anywhere in the world, and
I could send my cartoon.
So a lot of people ask
me, all right, how
do you do your cartoons?
All right.
So one thing is that I'm
constantly trying to ingest as
much information as I can from
a whole variety of sources.
TV, the Web mostly.
Radios really great.
And of course, you're reading
some magazines as well.
But keeping up is
really tough.
So now, because I consider
myself a columnist, my first
job is being a journalist,
gathering the information.
But now, I have to try to get an
angle on an information and
not find out what's funny today,
but find out what is
important today.
And once I've got that, now I
have to take that idea and
turn it into a cartoon.
And in the beginning, it's
awfully difficult.
So what I do is I give
myself lots of paper.
I put it on my desk.
And I think and draw
at the same time.
And part of this about the
creativity, you try to fire
between the two halves of you
brain, the logical and the
creative, saying what is
interesting and what logically
would work.
But then, also what will be cool
and what will be funny.
And I'm doing lots
of sketches.
And my first sketch is often
virtually hieroglyphic.
In fact, let me show you one
of my early sketches for a
cartoon I did recently.
Can you see that?
AUDIENCE: It's a Frank
Gehry design.
KEVIN KALLAUGHER: That's it.
[LAUGHS]
It's a perfect--
you can see obviously what's
going on here.
But this was, I was commissioned
to do a cover for
"The Economist" recently.
And they wanted me to do
something about raising taxes
on rich people.
So I started to conjure up what
would be a good idea.
And I thought, how about
fox hunting?
That's the kind of thing that
rich people maybe do.
But I thought I'd give it
a little bit of a twist.
And instead of having fox
hunters chasing foxes, how
about if I have politicians
chasing rich people?
And so this was what my first
sketch looked like.
But the next sketch
is much clearer.
There you go.
OK But already, I'm beginning
to map out all the varieties
shapes and trying to conjure
up a composition.
The next sketch that I do on
top of that is getting a
little bit clearer.
You might be able to see some
of the characters appearing
down in the southeast
part of the drawing.
And the next drawing still is
getting more and more clear.
And at the same time while I'm
doing this in London, they are
playing around with the
captions, the titles of the
publication.
And they're also working on
compositions as well.
Someone might have something
like this. "Follow the Money."
Or "Pursue the Rich." I think
we have another one here.
Next, once we have settled on
the pencil sketch, I now am
working on the color, including
creating the
caricatures that are
going to go in it.
And here, you can see the
Barack Obama version.
And finally, when I've painted
it all, it looks like this in
watercolor.
And it's quite large
this one, I think.
And this whole process between
this, actually, the original
sketch that I showed you
and this finished color
cover, is 36 hours.
36 hours from that little
sketch and all those
iterations.
So one of the things about being
in my craft is that you
have to love deadlines.
Not everyone loves a deadline.
We live on a daily deadlines.
I mean, we're creating art and
commentary on a deadline.
In fact, I tell people never
go to the pub with a
cartoonist, because we will wait
'til one minute before
closing time before we offer
to buy you a drink.
Because we just love
deadlines.
It's just the way
that we operate.
So now a little bit
onto technology.
I wanted to tell you guys
a little bit about it.
We're always concerned about
what's happening to
newspapers, because it's the
natural home of cartoonists.
But my senior thesis at
University back in 1977 was a
13 minute long animated cartoon,
back in the old day,
when you had to hand draw cells
after cell after cell.
And the first thing I want to
show you here is that I've
been an artist in residence at
UNBC, which is a university
near Baltimore.
And I've been exploring some
cool stuff in animation.
But I'm going to start
off with this--
there's going to be a 30 second
television commercial
I'm going to show you here.
It aired in 1986.
It won several international
animation awards.
It was done with the help of
Richard Williams, who's the
animation director for "Who
Framed Roger Rabbit" and won
several other awards.
And it stars Margaret Thatcher
and Neil Kinnock, who was the
Labour-- at the time.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Did you consider that some
newspapers treat politics with
a trace of bias?
One side always right.
The other side, always wrong.
Or the other way around.
Today, we'll show all
politicians without bias-- not
as saints or devils, but
ordinary people.
-Hi-ya!
-Order!
-Oh!
-"Today" covers the newspaper,
not the news.
"Today," the newspaper that's
broken the mold.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
KEVIN KALLAUGHER: All right.
Give it up for that cartoon.
Isn't that awesome?
That is so cool.
So that was really great.
I get a kick out
of seeing that.
I've seen it so many-- it's just
really beautifully done.
It's really funny.
It's smart.
And so you see something like
this that excited me about the
prospect of saying, wouldn't
be great to make political
cartoons come alive?
Wouldn't that be awesome?
But in those days, it was a
problem, because this took
three months to make 700-some
odd drawings.
And the prospect of being able
to do something about news,
when news changes like this, but
animation was so slow, it
didn't seem possible.
Today, of course, new
technologies are allowing more
prospects and more possibilities
for animation to
become King.
And I'm extremely excited
about the possibilities.
I'm just going to share with
you just that one little
project that--
actually, a couple little
projects I did.
Back in the 2008 election cycle,
I worked with Second
City, the improv comedy troupe,
and did a nationwide
show with them.
But as part of it, I had built
a few life-size versions of
some of my caricatures,
including this one of George
Bush, and then turned them into
digital characters, like
a digital Hillary Clinton.
And I did a John McCain.
And as part of the my show, I
would do a live bit, where I
call live animation, where I
would be backstage in motion
capture suit with voice
recognition software on a mic.
And my character, let's say John
McCain, would appear on
the screen in front
of an audience.
We actually did a show at the
Yerba Buena Art Center here.
Packed house.
And we would have a live press
conference between the
audience and the cartoon
characters.
But for the Yerba Buena show,
which was really fun, we
actually did a dance off between
Barack Obama and John
McCain, whereby we would select
different dance styles
from the audience.
And then I would have to dance
as these characters to music.
And then the audience would vote
to see who would get a
certain amount of
electoral votes.
It was really kind of cool.
The last shows we did were in
New York City in Times Square.
We had a debate, actually,
between these two guys.
And I would actually do a
personal interview with them
during the debate.
In fact, I'm going to do one
right now with John McCain
here, Senator McCain.
You had Sarah Palin
as your candidate.
Do you really believe that she
was qualified to be president?
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-Listen, my friends.
Sarah Palin is qualified
to be president.
She has ridden caribou to hunt
polar bears with bazookas.
She has caught Chinook salmon
blindfolded with her teeth.
No community organizer in
Chicago has ever done that.
Right?
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
KEVIN KALLAUGHER: That's right.
Thank you.
Give it up for Senator McCain.
Thank you very much, Senator.
Thank you very much
for coming.
That's really great.
So in addition to doing these
3D cartoons, I've also now
been doing some 2D stuff as
well, including two cartoons
I'm going to show you here.
About a minute and a half each,
commissioned by "The
Economist" on economic terms.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[BIRDS CHIRPING]
-When the price of an asset
rises faster than can be
explained by economic
fundamentals,
it creates a bubble.
[POP]
[CRASH]
-And those bubbles include tulip
mania in Holland during
the 17th century, when the
prices of tulips reached
unbearable levels.
And South Sea bubble in Britain
a century later.
Here, speculators, which
included a vast array of
citizens, including
parliamentarians and a king's
mistress drove up the share
price of the South Sea Trading
Company with disastrous
results.
[POP]
[CRASH]
-There have been many others
since, including the dot-com
bubble in internet company
shares that burst in 2000.
[POP]
-And the bubble in house prices,
which when it burst in
2007, helped to trigger
the recent
political economic downturn.
[POP]
[CRASH]
-Economists argued whether
bubbles are caused by the
irrational behavior of crowds,
aided in part by savvy
speculators, or are the result
of misinformed consumers who
assume the inflated prices
are sensible.
Whatever their cause, bubbles do
not last forever, and often
end not with a pop,
but with a crash.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
KEVIN KALLAUGHER: There we go.
All right.
We've got another
one coming here.
One more to show you.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-When the prices of goods and
services rise rapidly,
families and businesses
suffer.
But on rare occasions,
when rising prices
skyrocket out of control--
[CRASH]
- --the result can be
catastrophic hyperinflation.
Hyperinflation is generally
caused by reckless governments
who let their money supply
grow too fast.
After the First World War,
German prices at one point
were rising at a rate
of 23,000% a year.
This caused the country's
economic system to collapse,
creating a political opportunity
for the Nazis.
More recently, in the former
Yugoslavia, 1993 prices rose
around 20% a day.
Later in July, 2008, Zimbabwe's
official inflation
rate reached an astonishing
231 million percent.
Typically, hyperinflation
quickly leads to a loss of
confidence in the country's
currency.
With the value of their cash
diminishing, citizens pursue
stable items like gold and
foreign currency as safe
stores of wealth.
-Yeah.
All right.
Uh-huh.
-Hyperinflation might not be
so bad if it was stable.
People and businesses could plan
for the future accounting
for high, but predictable
pricing.
However, there are no examples
of stable hyperinflation.
By its nature, hyperinflation
is an uncontrollable--
[BOOM]
- --and dangerous phenomenon.
[END VIDEO PLAYBACK]
-There we go.
All right.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
KEVIN KALLAUGHER: Thank
you very much.
Thank you.
So in this case, cartoons, I
believe animated cartoons can
work as great educational tools
and informative tools,
in addition to being sources
of commentary.
So anyway, before I leave this
portion of the conversation, I
wanted to say we do
other things too.
I've done a bunch of
beer labels for
some brewery in Baltimore.
That's kind of fun stuff.
Gives me a bit of a break away
from the normal hardcore stuff
of politics and stuff.
And my new book, which you guys
have seen, which has been
a great process.
This, by the way, was funded
through a Kickstarter
campaign, where we raised
$100,000, and so pre-sold
copies to 46 different
countries.
So it was a great,
great success.
And with that, we're now
on to the questions.
Thank you very much.
Thank you, guys.
[APPLAUSE]
KEVIN KALLAUGHER:
So you guys--
Hal, do you want to?
AUDIENCE: I have a question
about one of the first things
you said, which was that
the number of political
cartoonists in the US was
slightly declining.
KEVIN KALLAUGHER: Yes.
AUDIENCE: So for other forms of
art, typically people like
us wouldn't be too concerned.
We would think well,
technologies going to
democratize everything.
There may not be as many
full-time cartoonists, but
anyone could be a
cartoonist now.
KEVIN KALLAUGHER: That's right.
Sure.
AUDIENCE: But it doesn't seem
like it's turned out that way.
So why haven't we seen the
internet flourishing with
clever political cartoons
from amateurs?
KEVIN KALLAUGHER: That's a
really great question.
So one of the things, first of
all, the cartoon skill set
that we discussed a lot here is
also one that's not easily
transferable.
It's really finely tuned, highly
refined skill set.
Some of it is built for the
print, cross-hatching, and
lines, and black ink.
But some of it about the
concepts and the notion that
you have to really be a great
study of politics is something
that is very specific.
In some ways, we're kind of like
decathlon athletes, where
we're juggling an awful
lot of things.
And those kind of skill sets
aren't often found in any
individual.
So I even think that if you
open it up for the general
public, there still would be
just very few people who would
qualify for that, or maybe
be able to assert that.
But then there's a second part
is, is that true, the
cartoonists, they may have
this new field, new wide
audience, and maybe even
find niche audiences.
But as we're finding, trying
to make money on the web in
many of these endeavors
has been tricky.
But I still remain incredibly
hopeful that there's going to
be new possibilities.
And I think that we're already
beginning to see this a little
bit in our cartoon world.
But I'm also seeing that the
young people, anybody under
the age of, say, 25, who
didn't grow up reading
newspapers, that the cartoons
like the ones I produce are
not magical to them in the
same way it was for my
generation.
What's magic to them is
animation, or the things that
they've seen both on the web,
but also on television.
And they might gravitate
in that area.
We're also seeing lots of
individuals who are able to
express their views on lots
of different outlets.
And so maybe there's a--
for a long time, when you had
only a very few newspapers,
and only a handful of letters to
the editor that could ever
get into a newspaper, that the
cartoonist often spoke for the
volumes of other people who
felt misrepresented.
And they really loved what
a cartoon could do.
And so now maybe other
people are speaking,
taking those voices.
But I feel confident that the
history of mankind trying to
express itself in pictures is
something that's gone back to
the days of cave painting
And that with the new
opportunities and possibilities,
people will
find ways to make that work.
And so I feel encouraged,
even though the official
professionals as we define
them are shrinking now.
It'll probably get
worse before it
gets better, I believe.
But I do believe strongly
that it will get better.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
I curious about memes and this
idea that photo illustration
has become the cheap
trick for that.
But here's inspiration.
But on a more serious note,
the other trend you were
talking on these last two
cartoons is that you're doing
things that are less opinion
and more factual or
training-oriented.
What came to mind as we were
watching the bread rocket
through the sky was Salman Khan
and the Khan Academy and
the kinds of whiteboard
chalk talks, or so on.
And that linked to another one,
which is that, where is
the room perhaps--
clearly, the best art here has
been where opinion, or taking
aspects of someone's character,
or you're doing
something subjective.
But where might there be room
for objectivity in terms of
trying to tell a stories as
facts and possibly data
visualization.
Because we're saying an
incredible amount of
innovation and budget moving,
say from editorial cartooning
to editorial data.
You've probably seen that in
"The Guardian" amongst other
institutions.
And where might there be
opportunities in your own work
to try and work more with data
without turning into "US
Today" cartoon sharks.
KEVIN KALLAUGHER: Yeah.
No, I think that there
is going to be more
opportunity with that.
And of course, the thing is that
when you have animation,
it gets a little bit
more expensive.
But the animation software
is getting faster.
And then there's also
different--
I told you before that I'm
a storyteller, basically.
And I'm using narrative, I'm
using pictures, and so on.
And there's more kind of
storytelling software that's
becoming available, that we're
going to see different kinds
of cartoons, I think, that
are going to be easier to
assemble, and then become more
relevant on the web.
But I think then, at the end
of the day, whether you're
working for Pixar, or you're
working as a cartoonist, you
can have all the great
technology behind you, it's
your storytelling.
The capability of storytelling
the brings value to
that sort of thing.
And so as a result, one of
things that cartoonists tend
to have, that's where
they are wired best.
They're best at storytelling.
HAL BAILEY: Speaking of
storytelling and technology,
can you tell us a little bit
about your app, DaggersDrawn.
KEVIN KALLAUGHER: Yeah,
yeah, yeah.
That's right.
In fact, I have Apurva
Shah, who helped
design the app for me.
And actually, I'm going
to ask you maybe.
We'll get the mic over here.
I have a new app they just
got launched, just
about a week ago.
DaggersDrawn.
It's called DaggersDrawn.
But there's a problem with it
that's it's not available on a
really great platform.
Do you want to pass
the mic over here?
You want to to a little
bit about it?
I'm sorry about that.
AUDIENCE: What platform
would that be?
KEVIN KALLAUGHER:
That's right.
APURVA SHAH: Hi.
Great to see everyone here.
Right now, it's an iOS app.
Hopefully, we'll do an
Android version soon.
But it's built with the
company I founded.
It's called Whamix.
It's a story-telling
platform, actually.
And we took Kal's book, which is
beautiful, has these great
illustrations.
And rather than having just an
eReader experience, create a
complement to the book.
So it has a lot of video
footage from him.
He provides insight on the
cartoons, and some of economic
terms that you saw as well.
And it tries to create an
experience where you can be
more interactive with it.
So please check it out.
AUDIENCE: So my question was,
has any politician ever
accosted you because of your
caricature of them?
KEVIN KALLAUGHER: Right.
Well, really interesting about
this, because obviously, in
many parts of the world, the
defining characteristic of
freedom of expression
is whether you can
draw the head of state.
But because you can draw the
head of state, that doesn't
mean they necessarily like it.
But a smart politician like
Ronald Reagan would have the
cartoonist come to the White
House and would enjoy having
his face drawn by everybody
around him.
But ever since then, because
they're wanting to control the
message, every major politician
tries to keep
cartoonists at a distance.
So most of the time where you
have, in the US, real impact
with politicians is in the local
area, whether you're
with governors or with mayors
and that sort of thing.
And I had my own personal
experience with the governor
of Maryland named William Donald
Schaefer, who used to
carry my cartoons around
in his pocket.
And at every press conference,
make comments
about what I did.
And there was a point where,
right before he left office,
he wrote me a letter.
And he wrote many letters, many
of them which I could not
even say in front of a mature
audience, even.
And he said, dear Kal, please
send me the cartoon that
appeared in "The Baltimore
Sun," dated so and so.
And this is after seven years
of him going nuts about me.
That's public enemy
number one.
It was great.
But I read on.
As you want money for these
depressing monstrosities, I
herein attach the value that
I've put upon your cartoons.
And he taped a penny to the
letter and wrote "Overpaid" on
the top of it.
So now, this letter is like a
diploma hanging in my office.
And so you do get these
kind of interactions.
But the other thing is that
"The Economist" is read by
Presidents.
I mean, we have pictures with
them having the magazine
walking in.
So you know they're
reading your work.
But you'll never hear
from them direct.
You hear through
their proxies.
And there's some politicians who
hate everything you draw,
and other ones who love
everything you draw.
Steve Forbes, who ran for
president a few years ago,
when he dropped out, he
contacted every cartoonist
around the country and got every
single cartoon drawn of
him for his library.
So it's funny how
people respond.
AUDIENCE: When I look at your
cartoons, like we call them,
the longer I look at them, the
more detail I see in them.
And every detail has
meaning to it.
It's like, seven layers of
meaning to a single picture.
It's amazing how you
can do that.
How long does it take to
draw a caricature?
KEVIN KALLAUGHER: Thank you very
much for that question.
My cartoons, the black and white
ones you see, it's a
full day process.
And I have to be very
efficient here.
You have a very hard deadline
at the end.
And when you're finished, you
want to deliver something that
has all those layers
to it, if you like.
Partly, I do it as an
honor to my reader.
I feel that if you feel like
I'm investing in you, then
you're going to reward me by
spending two or three more
seconds with the cartoon.
And then it gives you the
opportunity to create a
relationship over time.
In fact, I like to say every
cartoon is a sentence.
And a week is a paragraph.
And then over time, we're having
a long conversation
that we have to carry on
for decades, hopefully.
And the idea, however, is that,
for any conversation, is
you want to keep
it interesting.
And the way to keep it
interesting is you want to
have variety in it.
Some of my cartoons
are serious,
some of them are funny.
Some of them have caricatures.
Some have symbols in them.
I've used all these different
tools in order to keep it, so
every time you open the cartoon,
the newspaper, the
magazine, you don't know what
you're going to get.
So I start the day, usually say,
up 'til 10 or 11 o'clock
cogitating the news.
Now, of course, I'm constantly
Constantly ingesting
information.
Listening and trying to
come up with ideas.
And I never come up with
ideas ahead of time.
You're always working on that
day, because there's always
news that changing
and breaking.
I don't have anything
in reserve.
And so by about midday,
I should have
settled down on my idea.
I spent three hours then doing
the pencil sketch, refining
like I did with that cover you
saw, getting everything right.
I then let the editors
know, here's what the
I'm thinking of doing.
We get it signed off on.
And then it takes me three
hours to apply
the ink to the drawing.
I'm using an old-fashioned quill
pen and a bottle of ink.
Scratch, scratch, scratch.
Think.
Headphones on.
It's a wonderful experience.
And then maybe by 6 o'clock,
7 o'clock, I might have the
thing completed.
So, it takes that long.
And then, you add color to
it, it can be longer.
But all this experience is is
that every cartoon you do is a
practice for the next cartoon
you're going to do.
Because when you work
on a deadline, you
never finish the cartoon.
You have to stop it.
If you wanted to finish, you'd
need another five, or six, or
seven hours to get it the
way you want it to.
But you have to stop.
And at that point, you
learn the lessons.
And then you apply them
to the next one.
And it's part of the reason what
I love about my craft, is
that I feel that a decade from
now, two years from now, I'll
be better than I am today,
because you're constantly
learning and building
on your experiences.
AUDIENCE: I remember the cartoon
you did for 9/11.
And I also remember the
controversy over the headline
that "The Onion" printed in the
same time period, which
was perhaps very insightful,
but also quite irreverent.
And I was just wondering, there
is an irreverence that
you draw with about
political leaders.
And I'm just trying to figure
out the line that you draw in
terms of what subject matter for
education, versus subject
matter for satire, versus
subject matter for
irreverence.
KEVIN KALLAUGHER: Yeah.
That's such a great question,
because this is
thing about the line.
First of all, I've travelled
the world representing the
United States and the State
Department, speaking of
freedom of expression in a
whole array of countries.
And that question is asked
to me all the time.
And as I reflect, I realize
that I ask myself that
question every day.
Whenever I'm doing a cartoon,
you're assessing who your
audience is.
How are you going to try to be
able sometimes push the line
on the cartoon, or get a
point across without
going over the line?
And one of the things is that
the line is constantly moving.
And where it was yesterday
is not going to
be where it is today.
In every country, every culture,
they've all got
different places.
And when our cartoonists get
together, we're in that
situation too.
And we've had situations where
almost all of us have gone
over the line, either
deliberately or by
mistake over time.
And so, it is something that
you have to be very, very
careful with.
Now part of the thing about my
work is that my cartoons are
very detailed.
And so one of the things that
I definitely try to do with
all the freedom that I have
is to be very responsible.
So I want to make sure I'm not
doing cartoons that could be
deemed to be racist or sexist.
I feel that I can cover any
subject that I want, but it's
how you cover the subject
inevitably that
gets you into trouble.
And so even if I wanted to do
something about the Prophet
Muhammad, I could probably do
a cartoon on that subject.
But maybe opt now to draw the
Prophet, because I know that
the outrage that it would create
and people would lose
track of the point that
I wanted to make.
Because at the end of the day,
I want to be an effective
commentator.
I want to get a point across.
And I want to engage
the opposition.
I don't want to be speaking
to the converted.
And so in order to do that, you
have to realize that you
can't step so much on the toes
of those people you disagree
with that they stop listening.
Otherwise, what's the point?
Because at the end of the day,
I feel like we're kind of an
instrument of democracy.
We're trying to get a
conversation going using these
little pricks, these little
incitements, I guess, where
cartoon get do to the brain
firing a little bit.
But having said that, there's
always somebody ticked off
with your cartoons.
So when I worked in the UK, I
worked in addition to "The
Economist" from other
newspapers.
In the UK, you have a situation
where you have about
a dozen daily newspapers, and
each one is targeted to a
special socioeconomic
demographic.
Down market, left wing, up
market, right wing, and
everything in between.
Here in the US, we have one
newspaper per market usually.
And which means it's read by
everybody in all the different
demographics.
So every cartoon you do is
ticking somebody off.
And believe me, they
let you know.
About 85% of my contact with
the public is negative,
because we deal with ridicule.
We're making fun of people.
We're making fun of
the point of view.
And they get upset, and
they let us know.
And so as a result,
you can't help it.
But the question is, is are you
still being fair within
that realm?
And it's a tricky area.
But believe me, we're thinking
about this all the time.
Then add the fact that our
audience is now global.
I can do a cartoon here.
And then, it could be
willfully misread or
misrepresented in
another culture.
And then, you could have
all sorts of problems.
So it's a really interesting
time.
Seriously, interesting time to
be doing what we're doing.
AUDIENCE: Did that problem start
after the internet, or
was it there before when "The
Economist" was just in print?
KEVIN KALLAUGHER: Well,
yes. "The Economist"--
because in some ways, if you
imagine, "The Economist" was
like the internet before,
because it was one of the only
global publications.
And so it was read everywhere.
And yeah, we would have
situations where, for example,
I did a cartoon of
Indira Gandhi.
It appeared on the cover.
It arrives in India.
They see it.
Don't like it.
They confiscate it and burn all
the copies immediately.
In Singapore, even to today,
they'll go in and they will
cut out articles.
There was a time, I think it
was Singapore, where every
night, every single individual
magazine that went in would be
individually censored.
This article would
be blacked out.
This picture would be cut out.
And there's still some
countries where
that happens today.
And also, even "The Economist"
will do a cover.
Now some of "The Economist"
covers can be
a little bit edgy.
And it will be well-understood
in certain parts of the world,
and not understood at all in
other parts of the world.
And you can also imagine too
that now with "The Economist,"
we get comments online.
If we some sort of major article
about China, Russia,
Iran, and I think there may be
one other country, they have a
legion of government-paid trolls
who just go out there
and bombard you with all of
their opinions and so on.
So you're going to get reaction
when you're global
with anything, I guess.
Well, good.
How about some drawing?
Now we get to do
some fun stuff.
I'm going to do some drawing
here for you guys.
And I'll be around too if
anybody has questions
afterwards.
And I'll also be happy to
sign your books there.
OK.
So let me find my
fabulous tool.
My magic machine.
The ink machine that
I've got here.
So I'm going to draw
some of these guys.
And I've drawn these guys
thousands of times.
So I can draw them
fairly quickly.
And as I told you before,
these things
take me a long time.
And I couldn't, for
example, draw my
own father from memory.
And it's because I haven't
drawn him many times.
When you draw somebody, it
registers in a different part
of the brain, because you've
had the opportunity to
evaluate their face,
break it down,
work it into an equation.
So actually, these guys I can
do quickly, but it's only
because I've done them
a thousand times.
And I'm going to start
with Al Gore.
He's one of my favorite guys.
Because he invented the
internet, for example.
And he's a guy who collects
cartoons.
And I've seen him up
close a few times.
And so I can tell you the
shape of his head or
something like that.
OK?
So that's kind of Al
Gore right there.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE]
Island Al Gore.
KEVIN KALLAUGHER:
That's right.
And so, Al Gore.
He's got Ronald Reagan kind
of hair that kind
of goes like this.
He's got ears from
"Star Trek." They
kind of go like this.
He's got nose, a straight,
bony nose.
Flared nostrils like this.
Kind of goes like this.
He's got a little Elvis mouth.
Kind of go like this--
likes this.
And already, you can start to
see him appear from here.
So anyway, here's the
thing about Al Gore.
Like I said, I've seen
him up close.
And many people think that he
lost the 2000 election in
Florida because of a
few hundred votes.
And I'm telling people that is
not the reason why he lost.
Al Gore lost the election in
Florida because Al Gore has
got the eyes of death.
The eyes of death.
That's what he looks
like, really.
If you see him up close, that's
kind of where he is.
Seriously.
OK.
Poor Al.
All right.
Who would like this?
Anybody want this?
Who wants the drawing?
Here you go.
All right.
OK.
So the next one we'll do is--
oh, I'll keep on the
Democratic theme.
We'll do John Kerry.
So John Kerry's got the long
face thing I was telling you
guys about.
So he's got kind
of a long face.
He's got a long face.
He has got a really long face.
And you know, I'm thinking
maybe that's not right.
Let's try this.
OK.
All right.
So this is better here.
So this goes like this.
And then he's got here, and
his nose is like this.
And then his eye
goes like this.
And he's got the hair, the
Brillo pad hair that kind of
goes like this.
And his ears kind
of go like this.
And then this connects
down like this.
And there's a line here
and a line here.
What do you think?
John Kerry.
Not bad.
All right.
Who wants a long cartoon
for their office?
Who wants it?
Anyone?
Put your hands up.
Who wants it?
Right there.
OK.
Actually, you'll get
the next one.
You'll get the next one.
All right.
John Kerry, Al Gore.
Bill Clinton.
Let's do Bill Clinton.
All right, so here's
the thing--
[LAUGHS].
So here's the thing.
I am a method cartoonist.
You guys have heard of
method actors, right?
Method actors, they get into
the part and the character.
Well, I get it to my cartoons.
And my wife, she was at
a studio with me.
She goes crazy because I start
talking like George Bush or
Ross Perot.
And so all these people.
But anyway, so Bill Clinton
is a great person.
You have get into his head.
Although inside his head,
believe me, there's a lot of
crazy stuff going
inside there.
So I'm getting into him, and
I start talking like him.
And Bill Clinton, he's got this
kind of pug nose like
this, and little teeth that
look like a bunny rabbit,
sticking like this.
And he's got a cheek.
Little cheeks here.
And he's got eyes.
And he's got lots of bags.
Have you noticed recently?
Poor guys.
Lots of bags.
Which is a problem, because he
travels so much, and they
charge for every extra bag.
It's terrible.
It's bad.
Really bad.
Poor guy.
OK.
And his hair's very white now.
I tried, and never did that
thing I told everybody about.
And his chin, he's kind
of a big Bill
Clinton chin like this.
And his thick neck, and
something like that.
What do you guys think?
Is that Bill Clinton?
Not bad.
All right.
Somebody had his hand up way
back there really early.
So, yeah.
So there you go, mate.
There you go.
Bill Clinton.
All right.
So let's try George
H. W. Bush.
Now I'm going to do him twice.
I'm going to do him first what
he looked like when he first
came into office.
And here's the thing.
When somebody first comes into
office, the caricatures of
them look like the
photographs.
They actually are
close to that.
But in time, the cartoonist and
you, the cartoon-consuming
audience, gets to know the face
so well, and we can start
pulling apart.
And then at the end of four
years, the caricatures and the
photographs don't look
anything alike.
You put them next to each
other, but everyone
knows who it is.
So let me what he looked when he
started, and then I'll show
you what he looked like
after four years. .
So when he started, this
is the profile.
This at the top of his head
here and his hair.
And this is the back
of his head.
Hair going down here.
Nothing sensational here.
He had a pretty big forehead.
He had a nose that was kind of
a little bit sharp like this.
Eyes went down like this.
Crow's feet coming out here.
Few lines going up.
He had an upper mouth
that went like this.
He had these little
grizzly teeth--
[LAUGHS]--
that went like this.
And then he had a chin that was
kind of like his son, like
W's, like this.
Line went like this.
His ear out the back here.
Little echo there.
And the glasses, which he
called the vision thing.
The vision thing was
here like this.
And he had a little kind of
scrawny neck like this.
So anyways, the thing
was, he looked like
an insurance salesman.
Like any insurance salesmen.
That was George H.W. Bush
at the beginning.
So let's see where he ended up.
All right.
Who wants this one?
Yes.
Here you go.
Let's see where he goes
at this end of this.
So at the end of four years,
the hair at the top.
A little bit thinner, but not
much difference there.
But the head shape turns in
kind of to a light bulb.
OK?
Kind of a light bulb
like this.
His ears now sticking out the
back of his head here.
The back of his hair
is going like this.
His nose is like a sharp
knife like this.
His eye is going all the
way down like this.
The lines are going way up
the forehead like this.
His upper mouth is
like a beak.
Little grizzly teeth down
here like this.
And then his chin's going
way out like this.
Like this.
And then his glasses are perched
way out at the end of
his nose like this.
And his neck has even gotten
smaller, and skinnier, and
scrawnier down there.
And that's what he looked like
at the end of four years.
Isn't that something?
It's crazy.
Crazy.
But it looked like
him, doesn't it?
There we go.
Who wants this one now?
Who wants this one?
Who wants it?
There you go.
OK.
All right.
Here you go.
Excellent.
George H. W. Bush.
All right.
Now George W. Bush.
W. Bush.
All right.
So now, George W. Bush
has got some ears.
So it means making these sort
of things is a bit tricky,
because usually, I need like
this much room for the ear
here, and this much
for an ear here.
So I'm going to draw his ears
first, just to make sure that
we have room on the paper.
And I'm going to draw
it like this.
Now when I've drawn George Bush,
here's the thing that I
learned is that I--
the State of the Union Address,
it's always really
good to see these politicians
live, not just look at photos.
So I record the State
of the Union Address
and watch it twice.
I'm the only person
who watches the
bloody thing twice.
Because I'm watching their
faces and seeing all the
various different things.
And one thing about him is
I recognize his nose was
something that was very
distinctive to him.
Most people didn't
pick that up.
He had nice little nose with
big flared nostrils.
And a set of parentheses here.
The mouth kind of goes down
like this and up on
one side like that.
And his teeth are
here like this.
Then he's got a chin, which is
a W, which kind of helps.
That's really good for
us cartoonists,
just in case we forgot.
All right.
Then we got the line
here that kind of
connects down like this.
And then his eyes.
He's got these little
teeny eyes.
Little teeny eyes like this.
OK.
And then we got the eyes.
The heavy brow kind of going
like this, and teeth here.
And then, this one
way up here.
He doesn't know what he's doing
up there, this guy.
Like this, OK.
And then we've got
these lines.
They have a scientific name.
They're called perplexoids.
He's got a lots of
perplexoids.
And his hair kind of
goes like this.
Come down the side like this.
And George W. Bush.
What do you guys think?
George W. Bush.
What do you think.
Yeah, I think so.
Not bad.
Here you go.
Always sit in the
front row, guys.
This is just a little hint.
Just take a little hint here.
So we're going to do now--
what we're going to do, we're
going to do Barack Obama.
I am going to draw, but we're
going to do a lesson.
We have some paper there.
You guys got pens with you?
All right.
Get a pen.
We're going to do a
drawing lesson.
I'm going to teach everybody
here how to draw Barack Obama.
This is a great thing to do.
Even if you think you can't
draw, believe me, you will be
surprised what's going
to happen here.
You can draw on your lap.
You can draw if you
have the book.
You can draw it on the
back of the book.
Don't use a permanent pen,
because [INAUDIBLE].
We have some big paper there.
Take a pad.
All right.
So what we're going
to do is this.
First, I'm going to do a
cartoon about Obama.
I'm just going to show
you a little thing.
My observation about Obama.
Then, I'm going to do
the step by step.
Very quickly what to do.
You guys watch.
And then, we're all going
to do it together.
OK?
It won't take a minute.
It's a lot of fun.
Pretty simple.
And I think this day,
you'll be very
pleased with the results.
Now first, I just want to
tell you a little bit
about Obama's face.
Now I have been watching
his face carefully now
for five or six years.
And one thing about
his face, he's got
a very strong profile.
So the profile's kind
of like this.
He's got kind of big ears that
some people make a lot of.
But his heavy brow
is a big thing.
The sun hits is forehead.
The brow casts his eye
off into a shadow.
You can see a little
bit of it there.
He's got a nose that's not
particularly distinctive,
except he has got a little
mole there on his left
nostril, which you guys will now
never take your eyes off
of when you see him next.
Seriously, it's this little mole
that moves up and down
when he talks.
All right.
So then, he's got
this upper lip.
Big shadow there.
Beneath the bottom lip is
something like this.
And he's got this muscle here,
which is very distinctive on
him, becoming very apparent.
And his chin.
And already, you could start to
see the character appear.
So anyway, here's the thing
about his face.
It's that Barack Obama has been
hounded by these birthers
who suggest that he was not
born in the United States.
They say he was not
born in Hawaii.
On the island of Hawaii.
And looking at him and his
strong profile, I'm beginning
to think there might be
something to this.
Because I think Barack Obama
was born on Easter Island.
You see?
That's what I think.
I think that there's a lot
of parallel there.
So anyway, that's my first
evaluation of Barack Obama.
Who wants it?
Right here.
OK.
All right.
So now the lesson.
Barack Obama lesson.
Well, watch what I'm
going to do.
OK.
We're going to break this down
to very simple shapes that
everybody can do together.
Watch this, and then
we'll do together.
So what we're going to do is
we're going to start with a
sideways C. We're going to do
two vertical lines and a
horizontal line going
like this.
And we're going to
fill them in.
Then we're going to do a shelf
like this, shelf like this.
We're going to do a
line like this.
A line like this.
We're going to do a letter C
here with another one inside.
A second one here reversed
on this side.
We're going to do an upside
down letter C like this.
Then, we're going to do
two heavy brows here.
Now I've got the thick pen.
I can make it easily thick,
but you guys will
have to work at it.
Really make it nice and thick.
We do another line, and then
that could be where his eyes,
which is a little dot on it.
Halfway down, we're going
to do a little squiggle.
It's Is going to go one, two,
three, and then it's going to
come around and get his little
thing going on there.
Then we do between here the M.
M. And we're going to fill in
the top like this.
We're going to fill in
this one like this.
We're going to do a little
bit underneath.
And then do a set of parentheses
that are going to
almost connect at the bottom.
We're going to put
this thing in.
You guys know what
this is called?
The Obama.
This is the Obama.
We're going to give
him an Obama.
And then we're put his
little skinny neck.
And we can even have him giving
a big thumbs up to our
friends at Google.
And this is what we're
going to do.
So this is going to
be Barack Obama.
OK.
Very simple.
The question is, do you guys
think we can this?
And the answer is, yes we can.
All right?
Are you guys ready?
Can we do this?
AUDIENCE: Yes we can.
KEVIN KALLAUGHER: All right.
Good.
Let's see if we can
make this happen.
I'm going to stick this one over
here so everybody can use
it as a model.
Are you ready?
So we're going to do this.
We're going to start with
a sideways C like this.
Let's get a horizontal
line and two
vertical lines like this.
And we fill those in
with additional
texture for added realism.
For added realism.
Let's get a shelf sticking out
like this, and another shelf
sticking out like that.
And then let's get a little
coming down like this, and
then a line coming
down like that.
Then we get a letter C here.
Letter C. Another letter C, and
reverse on this side here.
Follow up with a--
this is where you're going
to have to do some work.
Get these heavy brows
going here.
Get those heavy brows.
Give it some work.
And if you got those down, let's
get a line underneath
here with an eye like that.
Halfway down.
Let's do that little
squiggle thing.
One, two, three.
And then let's get a squiggle
around like that.
And then at the bottom,
let's give it a
letter C upside down.
And now halfway between these
two, let's get the letter M.
One, two, three, and four.
Letter M across.
And fill in that top bit.
And then let's go underneath
like this.
Give it a little shadow
underneath.
All right.
Now we get that set
of parentheses
going here like this.
And they're going to be nearly
connect at the bottom.
And we'll give him that
little skinny neck.
Do it if you like
with his arm.
But there's just two more very
important steps once you've
gotten this far.
OK.
So the first thing that you all
have to do is hold up your
cartoon and show me.
Let's go.
Hold them up.
Come on.
Let's see the drawings.
Hold them up.
Let's see.
That's very good excellent.
Excellent.
No, no.
Don't Keep on showing them.
Up here, let's see.
There you go.
Excellent.
Very good.
Good going, guys.
Excellent.
Good.
Now the next and most important
part is you must
sign these cartoons.
All right?
Now I have seen those
cartoons.
Do not sign my name
to those cartoons.
Let's sign the cartoon,
because here's what's
interesting.
Last time some of you guys drew
was probably when you
were six years old.
And it's a whole lot of fun.
And here's the thing about
drawing, is that it is kind of
a latent muscle in your brain.
Particularly as we got so much
technology at our disposal,
this very tangible, physical
thing of letting your brain
connect to your hands and
produce something out of
nothing is magic.
If you want to be a magician,
the best and easiest way to do
it is to draw.
So one of the things I also
have to add is that for a
time, I was the president of an
international human rights
group dedicated to cartoonists,
where this act of
drawing is a very dangerous
thing, and where over half the
world, we couldn't even
have this meeting.
Where the police would
march in, and you
guys would be arrested.
And I'd disappear not
to be seen again.
And it seems kind of funny that
cartoonists could have
this happen.
But the crime that we would be
all doing is laughing at our
own head of state.
And currently, there is
cartoonists around the world
who are being jailed, tortured,
and murdered because
of what they do.
And so the fact that first, I
can do this incredible job--
been doing it for 35 years.
I can stand here, and I can
share it with you guys.
We can have a laugh together.
We could do all this stuff
and not worry.
And yet, we don't all have to
agree with the stuff that
we've seen here together To me,
it is an amazing thing.
That is magic.
And I want to thank you guys for
the opportunity to do it.
[APPLAUSE]
KEVIN KALLAUGHER: Thank you.